giant freaking robot did a video a
couple of days ago basically announcing
that a new Stargate series and movie
were on the way and we all went
let's wait until somebody a little bit
more reliable says that it's happening
well they have welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so if you are a regular side tracker you
will know that for a year now I've been
saying that we're going to be getting a
new Stargate series and I exclusively
told you first
that's actually Amazon were talking to
penguin in a Parker Mark Fergus to
develop that TV series and potentially
movie that Stargate we're looking at
this to be a franchise not just a
one-off show or film look at my dog look
at my dog on the beach
yeah
I also first told you that actually
Amazon were looking at a movie probably
first and I've told you that quite
recently that um Jennifer salkey was the
head of Amazon movies at the moment
thanks to the movies the way to go we've
been waiting very patiently for an
official announcement again I told you
guys first that they were looking at a
May 1st sort of deadline really to
announce this and if it didn't happen
that it would probably then be next year
until we saw something
well the magazine deadline has just
released a story in the last 24 hours in
that story it announced that actually
Amazon are working to bring back a slew
of MGM projects
Pink Panther
Legally Blonde
RoboCop
and
Stargate
that they are looking to develop a
Stargate television series and that that
will probably be a movie first
just like I've been telling you for
absolutely months
so once again this channel when it comes
to Stargate at least has been first and
exclusive over and over again deadline
announced this as an exclusive reveal
Unfortunately they got that bit wrong
because it's not exclusive I'd already
told you
this isn't really just me being very
excited on the beach about Stargate
coming it's this close now to be
announced deadline is a newspaper and a
magazine or a website that regularly
Scoops everybody they regularly scoop
for itthr et cetera Etc
so this has not come from just a report
somewhere this has come from Amazon
so this is as close to that initial
official announcement that we're gonna
get this is virtually an official
announcement
Stargate is happening now in the article
it goes on to talk about a lot of these
projects and when they might happen and
it does actually say that we might not
get official announcements on some of
this stuff until early next year which
is again kind of what I'm being told
from what I was told very last
from a source that I do trust on this he
says actually the movie is going to be
announced this year then movie will be
announced soon
um I was told by may but let's see
that's getting close now
um but the TV series would probably not
get announced until next year and it
will go to MGM Plus
so when MGM plus announced its
development cast and everything for next
year's project and that will be normally
in January the TV series will get
announced
but this is an exciting day it is a big
day it is the day that we came one
massive step closer to getting the
project we all desperately want finally
announced but guys get the comments and
tell me what you're thinking is this the
big news is this a source that we can
finally actually lay our hat on and say
yes
Stargate is coming first
and how happy are you that you've been
following Sidetrack for all these months
knowing before everybody else that this
was happening
I personally love it because I still get
called alive sometimes it's very
frustrating but you know when sometimes
this happens and really justifies
everything I've said for well over a
year
it I I can't help but feel like I told
you so so I am away as normal on my
Caravan walking the dog
Harry say hi Harry Harry Harry say hi no
he's not listening
um he's just going to sniff everything
and pee and everything and make it mine
um
good boy Harry
so guys anyway get into the comments to
tell me what exactly what you're
thinking on this very exciting news
if you are new to the channel you've
been missing out on over a year of
Stargate reliable news
but still please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and as always please stay safe
I'll see you next time
the next time being a live video talking
about this big deadline news article see
you soon guys
[Music]